[Music]
[Applause]
for example I was watching America's Got
Talent
I was watching that show yeah and then I
hit the info button and it said talent
equals misguided confidence yeah I was
watching Teen Wolf yes
watching Teen Wolf and then I saw on MTV
and then I hit the button and it said
the prequel to barista with crushing
student loan debt whoa that's not as
good a show well I was watching Keeping
Up with the Kardashians yeah and then I
hit the info button it said now easier
than ever to tell if it's a rerun
I was watching I was watching
I was watching Book Expo discussion on
diversity and publishing on c-span 2 and
I hit the info button and it said
greetings only viewer look at this when
I was watching scream the TV series was
just premiered on MTV and then I hit the
info button it said I scream you scream
we all scream why did they make
[Applause]
dr. who I was watching the classic
sci-fi show Doctor Who
yeah then I hit the info button it said
great show to watch with your girlfriend
or alone Game of Thrones
I was watching Game applause then I hit
the info button and it said the show
that makes you wonder what happened
during George RR Martin's and finally I
was watching Conan the Destroyer on
Sundance Conan the Destroyer yeah and
then I hit the button and it said not to
be confused with TBS is Conan via Neuer
[Applause]
[Music]
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography